faux mais que se passe-t-il qu'est-ce
qu'il va annoncer est ce qu'il est papa
il a décidé de se mettre à la cuisine
est ce qu ils arrêtent youtube du câble
excuses et je sais que vous avez peur
quand la danse est un truc mais là c'est
que du bonus et que du kif déjà j'ai vu
ce tweet et puis quoi encore voudrait
qu'elle serait d'horreur c'est un film
le seigneur des anneaux trois heures
pour qui vous prenez les 12000 kert et
sarah et redescendez ok il ya un lien
entre ce tweet est ce que je vais vous
annoncer dans un instant mais sachez que
non ce n'est pas un cri d'horreur qui
sort le jour d'halloween c'est un
nouveau concept une vidéo beaucoup plus
longue qu'un serait d'horreur qui je
pense va vous plaire et qui évidemment
fait frissonner en revanche j'entends
vos demandes le cri de désespoir au
sujet des traders il y aura donc dans
quelques jours un seuil d'horreur qui
sortira le thread horreur du mois
d'octobre et pour fêter la sortie de ce
que je vais annoncer dans cette vidéo il
y aura cinq histoires au lieu de 3 il y
aura un peu plus de 20 minutes ce sera
l'équivalent du thread horreur qu'on a
fait pour halloween l'année dernière
finale bref façon au projet je suis ému
ça me fait un truc à chaque fois
d'annoncer les gros projets là vous le
savez je suis fan de l'horreur ça fait
des années et des années que je joue à
des jeux d'horreur sur youtube et
maintenant sur twitter et ça fait un
moment qu'on fait des serait d'horreur
ça fait longtemps que je bosse là dessus
parce que je voulais vraiment que le
résultat soit à la hauteur de mes
exigences et mes espérances je suis fier
aujourd'hui de vous annoncer que c'est
le lancement des pré commandes d'une bd
inspirée des vidéos seraient d'horreur
avant de vous en parler plus en détails
je vous ai concocté un petit teaser pour
vous mettre dans l'ambiance teaser à la
fin duquel vous découvrirez le nom de la
bd et soyez attentifs parce qu'à
énormément d'un 10 sur les histoires de
la meinau
[Musique]
encore
et il donne envie teaser jeu l'adorent
blick c'est le nom de la bd oh ça me
fait quelque chose dans fin vous la
présenter j'ai en ma possession du tout
premier prototype de la bd c'est à dire
que deux dans la
ya même pas les pages imprimées encore
en revanche elle bon nombre de pages à
80 pages c'est les bonnes dimensions de
couverture c'est un peu plus grand et
large qu'une bd classique et surtout il
ya la couverture que je trouve vraiment
belle et c'est même pas la couverture
définitive puisque là elle est en papier
glacé en version maths ça donne ça je
vous parle dans un instant de pourquoi
jordaan rouge pour que l'on ait une
bleue mais celle ci je dois dire que on
n'aurait pas pu faire mieux vous y
retrouverez trois histoires d'horreur
originale écrite par lauren moi-même et
guillaume natas on a fait ça entre amis
on s'est régalé on s'est pris la tête
aussi beaucoup alors pourquoi une bd pas
un roman frérot je suis pas écrivain ça
va me prendre au moins cinq ans d'écrire
un roman vous le savez quand je suis un
truc j'ai beaucoup bossé dessus donc
évidemment j'en suis très fier là que ce
soit la couverture les histoires les
dessins et d'ailleurs en parlant des
dessins il ya trois dessinateurs qu'on
travaillait sur la bd puisqu'ils ont
chacun illustrer une histoire en plus
d'être une histoire différente à chaque
fois il ya une ambiance différente vu
que c'est pas le même dessinateur merci
de dire merci frédéric à bercy julien
pour votre travail vous avez été
monstrueux et aussi à camille pour le
story board qui a fait un travail
incroyable je suis très content parce
que déjà c'est le premier truc qu'on
sort autour du de l'horreur a parlé
serait d'horreur donc forcément ça me
fait quelque chose et puis surtout là on
est en train se crée un terrain de jeu
parce que blick ce ne sera pas que des
bd il y aura trois bd mais ça va être
aussi d'autres trucs comme par exemple
évidemment ça fait longtemps que j'en
parle des courts métrages vous le savez
on en a même regardé plusieurs fois en
live des pleins de courts métrages
d'horreur sur youtube dont certains
donné naissance à des films et j'ai pas
mal d'idées de courts métrages d'horreur
que j'aimerais faire ils s'inscriront
dans cet univers blick tout comme par
exemple les films conjure inc
s'inscrivent dans l'univers conjure in
que ce soit annabelle la nonne les
dossiers de warren tout ça pour le
moment la bd n'est pas disponible dans
le commerce elle est disponible
uniquement en précommande sur blick
project point com pourquoi on a fait des
pré commandes contrairement à olive
qu'on avait fait à l'époque avec maxence
et mon frère qui s'applique tourner la
page parce que ça laisse place à des
éditions limitées et un peu collector et
à des trucs rp et ça ça me fait kiffer
je voulais pas juste proposé de m'aider
je voulais aussi proposer différentes
options et donner un avantage à ceux qui
soutiennent les projets à leur genèse et
vous êtes très nombreux à chaque fois à
soutenir mes projets très vite à leur
jeunesse donc les précommandes pour moi
c'était l'occasion justement de régaler
ses jambes quels sont donc les avantages
de la pré commande excellente question
déjà vous la recevrez deux mois en
avance par rapport à sa sortie en
librairie c'est beaucoup de monde elle
sera disponible en librairie autour du
vainqueur mars et pour ceux qui auront
précommandé vous la recevrez fin janvier
mais surtout il ya trois packs de
précommande le premier coûte le même
prix que la bd quand elle sera dans le
commerce c'est à dire 15 euros sauf que
vous aurez cette cover exclusive qu'on
ne retrouvera plus jamais sur aucune bd
blick volume 1 après la fin des
précommandes dans 30 jours vous avez
aussi un petit cadeau c'est un stickers
aléatoire parmi ces stickers qu'on a
fait et aussi évidemment votre nom sera
dans les pages de remerciement à la fin
de la bd il ya ensuite deux autres packs
sur lesquels on s'est éclatés pourquoi
parce qu'on a fait des trucs très rp
dans ce deuxième pack vous aurez donc la
bd mais en plus vous aurez si stickers
mon stickers préféré étant celui ci pour
le moment vous ne savez pas ce que ça
représente mais vous comprendrez
faudrait que j'arrête de venir la bd ça
et c'est rôle vous retrouverez aussi une
lithographie et surtout une pochette
dans laquelle se trouvent trois pièces à
conviction liés aux histoires et vous en
apprendrez un peu plus encore sur
l'univers blick et enfin le dernier pack
le troisième pack suis là c'est vraiment
pour ceux qui veulent la totale vous
avez dans ce troisième pack tous les
éléments que je viens de citer mais
aussi un coffret collector un tee shirt
en édition limitée une enveloppe qui
contient tous les storyboards les fameux
et mon truc préféré à moi dans ce pack
vous avez une cover exclusive rouge qui
est selon moi absolument magnifique
franchement bref les précommandes sont
donc ouvertes à partir de maintenant et
pour une durée de 30 jours à l'issue
desquelles il sera plus possible de se
procurer l'un de ces trois packs mais
par contre pour les retardataires vous
retrouverez bien entendu en mars la bd
dans son format libre et rires donc
c'est exactement la même chose sauf que
la cover sera différente je suis ému de
vous annoncer ça c'est pas le seul gros
projets que j'ai cette année y en a
d'autres qui vont arriver évidemment
mais c'est l'un de mes préférés parce
que ça y est je me lance je sors un truc
d'horreur en dehors des serait d'horreur
donc c'est quand même stressant pour moi
j'espère que les histoires vous plairont
pour ceux qui vont se procurer la bd
j'espère que vous serez fat les
mécaniques j'y tiens on bosse
déjà sur un court métrage qui sortira
pas loin de la sortie en librairie
justement de la bd en mars et qui promet
qui promet c'est compliqué de faire un
court métrage d'horreur parce que c'est
pas si simple de faire peur via via une
vidéo mais honnêtement je pense qu'on a
de très bonnes pistes et surtout on a le
temps de peaufiner le truc là merci à
tous ceux qui précommanderont la bd du
coup ça fait plaisir et puis pour ceux
qui ça intéresse pas et qui sont pas
sensibles à ça il n'y a pas de problème
voilà j'ai fini je vous laisse découvrir
le site des précommandes blick project
points comme on se retrouve dans très
peu de temps pour ce fameux serait
d'horreur spécial cinq histoires qui
durera pas loin de 25 minutes quand même
donc je pense que je devrais être
rassasié et puis on se retrouve pour
halloween pour cette fameuse grosse
vidéo ce gros con cept je suis très
curieux de voir votre avis sur ce
concept je pense que vous allez même je
ne fais pas d'excès un truc nouveau je
suis un peu en stress normal ballack
sommes actuellement je lève pas les bras
je les aurai le prenez soin de vous et
se retrouve bientôt dans de prochaines
vidéos ciao tout le monde pis j'ai dit à
tout le monde naturel ça fait penser au
chat ou le monde piste de l'époque haut
[Musique]